the Lord alone is good evening - I mean
this is a hugely expensive project l
know if you're going to measure whether
it represents value for money to the
taxpayer
well we a desperately short of transport
capacity between our major conurbations
and HS - links london and the west
midlands which are the two largest
conurbations
in the country and then goes north west
to Manchester and northeast to Leeds
which are also hugely important both
economically and in terms of population
conurbations - so there is no free lunch
here if we don't build HS - and a new
rail line to 21st century technology
what we have to do is to modernize the
existing Victorian railway or to be more
precise in the case of London to
Birmingham pre-victorian railway because
the London and Birmingham railway was
opened in 1838 for the coronation of
Queen Victoria and modernizing and
trying to put more capacity longer
platforms changing junctions and all
that on a Victorian rally is hugely
expensive and difficult so if we didn't
do it just - we'd have to spend billions
on upgrades which wouldn't give us more
than a fraction of the benefits what
about this plot this price Oh 55 billion
I mean there are some wild estimates
flying around there was one in one of
the Sunday newspapers that suggested the
ultimate cost could be could be double
that I mean how are we had confidence I
that this project will come in on time
into budget
well you just interviewed Sir David
Higgins is the chairman of HS - Sir
David who was responsible for a large
part of the delivery of the
infrastructure for the Olympic Games is
one of the best infrastructure managers
in the world and the team he's got at HS
- is an excellent team and if anyone
couldn't deliver this this project on
time non-budget it's the team that Sir
David Higgins has put together at HS -
so that should give us reasonable
confidence but of course it's very
important these costs are kept under
control because the big problem not only
in this country but abroad and with
infrastructure projects historically is
that they aren't delivered on time and
on budget and it's very much their job
to see that we get it right this time
quite and that's a big issue though
isn't it I mean who is responsible for
the governance of this there have been
issues raised about the governance of HS
- in the recent past suddenly well the
the company HS - Limited which is a
government company is responsible for
the deliver
we of the project and that couldn't be
clearer it's a very clear allocation of
responsibilities and Sir David Higgins
and his management team hs2 are
responsible but of course it's
absolutely right that the government
keeps a beady eye on on what's going on
and I very much hope that that there is
real attention to cost control because
we do want to see that this railway is
opened the first leg from London to
Birmingham in 2027 which of course is
now only ten years years away so people
can we'll be able to factor it into
their plans whether they're companies
seeking to work out where best to go in
the country or people looking at where
to live so hugely important social and
economic decisions will be taken on the
basis of this railway and it's vitally
important that it's delivered on time
and on budget but this is why people
have concerns isn't it I mean the woes
that we've had at Karelian during the
last seven day show that it is very very
difficult even for the professionals
like Karelian to keep a handle on large
numbers of sprawling projects well there
are fortunately more than one company
that can operate in in this space there
are a large number of international
companies that can and what hs2 has done
is is to contract with a number of them
so that as Sir David Higgins said if
there were to be a problem with Karelian
they would be able to take control of
the contracts and award them elsewhere
but we very much hope that doesn't
happen
now what about Heathrow well we have you
the lot of concerns that the third
runway at Heathrow is going to get
kicked into the long grass again it
didn't get much of a mention in the
Queen's speech and it looks like final
decisions I'm going to be made until
next year now
well they the final decisions can't be
made until next year because there has
to be a process of parliamentary
consultation before Parliament as a
whole is able to to vote on the on the
final government statement of policy
that's required for Heathrow to proceed
but Secretary of State Chris Grayling
has said that he is determined to take
the Heathrow decision forward the
process of parliamentary consultation
has now begun and my commission the
National Infrastructure Commissioner has
said to the government that we expect
that decision to be taken in a timely
way which is next April or May which is
as soon as it can be taken so that the
essentially needed extra capacity
Heathrow can be put in place as soon as
possible
now separately you read
we said that a hard brexit would be the
worst mistake that this country has made
since appeasement in the 1930s was a bit
over-the-top I don't think it is a hard
brexit which would take Britain out of
the central economic institutions of the
European Union that's the customs union
and the single market would imperil our
trade and a very large number of jobs so
I obviously it's a very different
mistake that we'd be making from the
mistake in the 1930s the mistake in the
1930s was essentially a mistake of
defense policy not rearming fast enough
and taking enough notice of what was
going on with a hostile Germany this
would be essentially an act of economic
unilateral disarmament we would be
jeopardizing our trade with Europe for
as most people I think now coming to
realize no good reason at all so it's
essential that in in the jargon that
we're now using that we have what's
called a soft brexit which is that we
stay in the arrangements for the customs
union and a single market so that our
trade and the millions of jobs that
depend upon it can flow just as freely
after brexit as they do now I'll order
Danish we've got to leave it there
appreciate you joining us thank you